meredith standing by live at the white
house uh with more you know mark
rudy giuliani is a formidable presence i
first started covering him in
1982 when he was the mob busting u.s
attorney here in new york he cut crime
as new york city mayor two terms
changed the culture of this city guided
new york through 9 11 he has put his
heart and soul
into everything he does into his current
mission and he was even on with maria
bartoromo
this morning uh despite this uh uh
diagnosis of coronavirus what is the
reaction right now at the white house
eric good afternoon well i'm sure the
president also sending his well wishes
to rudy giuliani somebody that not only
people in new york know but is known
nationwide as a hero after 9 11 and of
course most lately as the
president's strongest defender when it
comes to the election legal challenges
the president broke the news less than
an hour ago on where else but twitter
this is what the president had to say he
said quote rudy giuliani by far the
greatest mayor in the history of new
york city
and who has been working tirelessly
exposing the most corrupt election and
history of the u.s
has tested positive for the china virus
get better soon rudy we will carry on
as i mentioned giuliani has been one of
if not the most loyal defenders of
president trump
he supported president trump for years
endorsing him back in april of 2016.
he's a mainstay on cable news as eric
mentioned also making an appearance
on fox news earlier today no indication
then
that he had known he was tested positive
certainly didn't say anything about this
diagnosis
we have not gotten an update on his
exact condition how he's feeling we've
reached out to him
waiting to hear back on that but the
president his own tweet offering his
well wishes
but giuliani has also faced some
criticism as you see right there outside
these state capitals
speaking to a number of people he was in
georgia he was in michigan this past
week uh without wearing a mask there
were a lot of people that would crowd
him
when he would go into those events i was
at the one in michigan
huge swarm of people that would be out
there but the former new york city mayor
of the latest news there
testing positive for coronavirus
meantime the president keeping a fairly
low profile today after that stop in
south georgia last night
campaigning for those two senate gop
candidates his first rally
since last month's election in his
speech the president said the stakes in
the peach state senate runoff
could not be any higher
the most important congressional runoff
probably in american history
there's never been a time like this
where
you have two at one time at least you
have two beauties
and you know what you also have two
beauties running against them
not to be outdone democrats are relying
on their own high-profile surrogates
former president obama campaigning
virtually on friday
democrats say more than 500 000 people
watched his event
and that the party saw a huge surge in
volunteers afterwards
tonight we are also watching what will
be going on with the food and drug
administration this week it's expected
to hold an emergency meeting
to discuss whether or not to authorize
pfizer's coronavirus vaccine candidate
a vaccine that's believed to be some 95
percent effective
today we heard from the health and human
services secretary alex azar who says
hhs is working hard to distribute the
vaccine as soon as it's approved
we're looking at a really historic
accomplishment you know six
months from when at the president's
direction i created operation warp speed
you know we're looking at having
multiple vaccines fda approved and
close to 40 million doses of fda
approved vaccine releasable by the end
of this year
the white house has made it clear it
would like to see a vaccine approved
sooner rather than later urging the fda
to get to work the fda pushed back last
week saying that they needed this time
to evaluate the data so we'll watch that
but
eric as you were mentioning the news at
the top of the hour that rudy giuliani
the president's
personal lawyer somebody who's a friend
to the trump family and well known
not only where you are in new york but
all over the country testing positive
for coronavirus
many of us of course wishing him well
eric